[Musik]
debatte über härtere strafen nach dem
jüngsten fall von kindesmissbrauch will
nun auch die justizministerin eine
verschärfung
verhandlungen über personalabbau bei der
lufthansa könnten bis zu 22.000 stellen
wegfallen
denkmäler als zielscheibe bei den anti
rassismus protesten in den usa rückt die
sklaverei vergangenheit des landes in
den fokus
[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den 19 uhr nachrichten an fronleichnam
mit norbert lehmann für den sport an
meiner seite schön moderator von mir und
wir beginnen mit einer debatte die
politik und öffentlichkeit seit den
jüngsten schweren missbrauchsfällen in
münster umtreibt sollen täter
grundsätzlich härter bestraft werden
sollte der missbrauch eines kindes nicht
generell als verbrechen gelten
bisher kamen solche stimmen er aus der
union
jetzt ist auch justizministerin
lambrecht spd auf diese linie
eingeschwenkt david geppert es ist ein
fall der bundesweit entsetzen ausgelöst
hat ein aufgedeckter pädophilen ring mit
zentrum in münster kindesmissbrauch
gefilmt ins netz gestellt nun nach tagen
des zögerns fordert die
bundesjustizministerin konsequenzen
härtere strafen wer kindern sexuelle
gewalt antut
der muss mit der ganzen härte des
gesetzes bestraft werden ohne wenn und
aber muss klar sein dass das ein
widerliches verbrechen ist und das muss
sich auch im strafmaß ausdrücken seit
tagen hatte die union
gesetzesverschärfungen gefordert sogar
ein vergleichbares strafmaß wie bei mord
rechtlich müssen auch konsequenzen
gezogen werden wir können noch nichts
dazu und dass wir das ladendiebstahl was
da an missbrauch passiert ist wie wort
und da erwarte ich dass es auf den
verbrechen bestraft wird das reflexhafte
rufen nach mehr strafen im gesetzbuch
hat noch kein kind geschützt wir
brauchen ein hohes entdeckungsrisiko und
eine hohe wahrscheinlichkeit das land
verurteilt wird wie schaffen wir das in
dem das umfeld aufmerksam ist die
jugendämter gut ausgestattet sind mit
personal und die polizei und
staatsanwaltschaften auch bei fällen wie
in münster seien schon jetzt bis zu 15
jahre freiheitsstrafe möglich betont
lamprecht doch auch fälle sexuellen
missbrauchs die nicht mit körperlicher
gewalt und misshandlung einhergehen zb
berührung von kindern in sexueller weise
sollen künftig härter bestraft werden
doch es gibt grauzonen nicht alle
handlungen die unter den begriff der
sexuellen missbrauchs fallen können in
zukunft zb verbrechen
werden der zungenkuss den ein
16-jähriger einer 13-jährigen gibt kann
ja nicht mit einer mindeststrafe von
einem jahr belegt sein
über verschärfung des strafmaßes will
kommende woche auch die
innenministerkonferenz beraten ausgelöst
durch die tat in münster die abgründe
einer gesellschaft offenbart von der
lufthansa kommen heute neue schlechte
zahlen die bei piloten und
flugbegleitern für angst sorgen
22.000 vollzeitstellen stehen auf der
kippe airline und gewerkschaften
verhandeln derzeit über ein sparpaket
die zeit drängt seit der korona krise
ist die große lufthansa ein
sanierungsfall angewiesen auf
staatshilfen
die kritik an den rettungsmilliarden der
regierung wächst hinten klingen am
frankfurter flughafen werden es
allmählich wieder mehr reisende
aber von normalität kann keine rede sein
und jetzt ist klar
bei der lufthansa stehen 22 1000
vollzeitstellen auf der kippe die
begründung der airline ohne signifikante
senkung der personalkosten während der
krise verpassen wir die chance eines
besseren restarts aus der krise und
riskieren dass die lufthansa group
deutlich geschwächt aus der krise
hervorgeht
betriebsbedingte kündigungen sollen etwa
durch teilzeit oder ruhestands modelle
vermieden werden die gewerkschaften
ringen mit der lufthansa um eine lösung
piloten und flugbegleiter können sich
auch gehaltseinbußen vorstellen aber
nicht bedingungslos
wir sehen auch das ist eine schwierige
krise und da sind personal überhänge
aber die mitarbeiter die brauchen die
garantie dass wenn sie jetzt etwas geben
wenn sie durch die krise helfen dass
ihre jobs dann auch gesichert sind
und da sind wir wohl noch etwas
auseinander kritik an der lufthansa und
der bundesregierung kommt von der
opposition aus berlin
die lufthansa soll mit 9 milliarden
öffentlichen geldern unterstützt werden
und ich bin der auffassung wir sind der
auffassung dass mit diesen geldern keine
massenentlassungen finanziert werden
dürfen
ich erwarte von der bundesregierung wenn
sie so viel geld ausgibt dass sie dann
gut verhandelt und deshalb erwarte ich
von der bundesregierung dass sie noch
verhandelt in zwei wochen müssen die
aktionäre dem geplanten rettungspaket
auf einer ausserordentlichen
hauptversammlung noch zustimmen
bis ende juni muss also eine einigung
her stefan schlosser mich gerade viel
zeit für derartig große probleme da
stimmt und dessen sind sich auch alle
beteiligten bewusst eben auch die
gewerkschaften und allen ist schon
länger klar dass es harte einschnitte
geben muss um das langfristige überleben
der lufthansa zu sichern
eben auch beim personal die
gewerkschaften die pilotenvereinigung
hat ja schon ein sparpaket auf den tisch
gelegt die piloten wollen auf 350
millionen euro beim gehalt verzichten
das wären dann einbußen bis zu 45
prozent bei einzelnen piloten und auch
die flugbegleiter sind zu finanziellen
zugeständnissen durchaus bereit
nur wollen die gewerkschaften im
gegenzug dafür eben einen
kündigungsschutz und genau dieser
jobgarantie will die lufthansa bisher
nicht bieten spricht lediglich davon
möglichst auf kündigungen zu verzichten
entscheidend wird also sein wie viel
geld die lufthansa am ende mit
verschiedensten maßnahmen einsparen kann
dazu gehört zum beispiel auch das
kurzarbeitergeld dass er möglicherweise
verlängert werden kann
und das ganze muss dann tatsächlich bis
zur hauptversammlung geklärt sein
und das ist in der tat nicht mehr viel
zeit es gibt also wirklich zeitdruck
vielen dank stefan schlosser in
frankfurt die korona krise hat viel
verändert auch das arbeiten selbst ein
viertel aller beschäftigten blieb oder
bleibt zu hause
videokonferenzen ersetzen reale meetings
der effekt weniger auto und flugverkehr
bessere luft der haken auch computer
brauchen energie und nicht zu knapp
wie also sieht eine corona
zwischenbilanz des umweltministeriums
aus per video konferenz statt weiter
wege die korona krise verändert das
arbeitsleben der deutschen das
umweltministerium hat berechnet der
personenverkehr ließe sich um bis zu
acht prozent reduzieren wenn es bei home
office und digitalen sitzungen bliebe
corona als klima chance glaube ich alle
gelernt dass so ein bisschen mehr auch
von zu hause aus machen können das neue
medien funktionieren
vielleicht auch ein bisschen darüber
nachdenken wenn man jede reise privat
oder dienstlich antreten muss es war
vorher immer so nee das geht alles nicht
und das ist alles zu kompliziert oder zu
wirtschaftlich nicht tragbar oder so und
dass das einmal plötzlich ja doch sehr
wohl tragbar ist umweltministerin
schulze liegt heute eine studie vor
grundaussagen virtuelles arbeiten sollte
wenn möglich verstetigt werden
es lohne sich auch regionalen online
handel zu fördern
für digitale umweltpolitik gebe es neue
perspektiven digitalisierungs zug erlebt
unsere routine haben sich in vielen
bereichen verändert und jetzt kommt es
darauf an zu schauen in welchen
bereichen es sich lohnt aus diesen
routinen brüchen die wir erlebt haben
bewusste routinen wechsel zu machen
kehrseite der neuen arbeits und
lebensweise der datenverkehr explodiert
allein in der korona zeit sei das
volumen um zehn prozent gestiegen
jede e-mail die wir verschicken bedeutet
einen höheren stromverbrauch und so groß
die entlastung ist im verkehrsbereich
desto mehr strom wird natürlich
verbraucht wenn wir nicht auch in der
energiepolitik die weichen anders
stellen
die botschaft der ministerin heute
digitalisierung und umweltschutz das
gehöre mehr denn je zusammen
die absicht ist formuliert aktionen
müssen noch folgen
schauen wir auf die aktuellen core ohne
zahlen bei uns bleiben die neue
infektion auf einem niedrigen niveau
im durchschnitt der vergangenen sieben
tage haben sich täglich 340 menschen neu
angesteckt insgesamt registriert die
johns hopkins universität rund 186 1000
infizierte davon gelten knapp 100 71.000
als genesen 8700 71 menschen sind in
verbindung mit dem virus gestorben hat
auch die deutsche polizei ein rassismus
problem
nach dem tod von george floyd in den usa
läuft auch hierzulande eine debatte die
spd-vorsitzende esken hatte von einem
latenten rassismus bei
sicherheitskräften gesprochen erhielt
widerspruch und machte sich nun bei der
polizei selbst ein bild peter kunz ist
deutschlands polizei möglicherweise
nicht jedermanns freund und helfer macht
sie unterschiede bei hautfarbe und
herkunft gibt es neben recht und ordnung
auch rassismus stimmen von der
polizeischule
ja es gibt rassismus in der gesellschaft
aber meine persönliche erfahrung und da
kann ich auch nur für mich sprechen ist
dass der in der polizei weniger
vertreten ist als in der gesellschaft er
sieben jahre durchaus auch gezielt
menschen mitnehmen nicht ganz so
demokratischen
und offenen verhältnis der welt aus die
polizeiakademie nienburg als
vorzeigeobjekt für musterschülern
uniform
der niedersächsische spd innenminister
pistorius hat die spd vorsitzende saskia
essen eingeladen
essen hat mit ihrer bemerkung zu
latenten rassismus bei der polizei eine
debatte ausgelöst und auch empörung ich
glaube dass der besuch dazu gedacht ist
dass ich was dazulernen und das andere
lernen zu verstehen was ich gemeint
haben dass wir so zu einem guten
austausch kommen
den studierenden erklärt sie dass es
kein generalverdacht sein sollte bei der
diskussion selbst bleiben kameras
draußen aber rassismus und gewalt bei
der polizei sind nach den vorfällen in
den usa jetzt auch hierzulande rede
thema ich glaube der polizei fällt es
schwer wenn das thema auf den tisch
kommt und wenn es fälle gibt
über die eine gesellschaft diskutiert
wird diesen widerspruch auszuhalten
zwischen dem eigenen selbstbild dem
eigenen selbstverständnis und dem fakt
dass es das problem in der polizei aber
eben doch gibt die spd vorsitzende hat
einen stein ins wasser geworfen damit
wellen geschlagen
ihr war das wichtig in die usa
während die untersuchungen über den tod
von george wright laufen fragen sich
viele muss nicht viel mehr auf den
prüfstand
die erinnerung an die us geschichte etwa
eine geschichte auch der sklaverei ja
sagen demokraten und fordern weg mit dem
andenken an rassisten us-präsident trump
ist empört doch viele legen bereits hand
an die monumente - drums eine weitere
statue die in der nacht vom sockel
geholt und unter jubel von demonstranten
abtransportiert wird es regt sich
widerstand im land gegen denkmäler für
sklavenhalter und armee für die im
bürgerkrieg für den erhalt der sklaverei
gekämpft haben immer mehr sehen in ihnen
symbole für rassismus wir kämpfen gegen
den staat der diese statuen behalten
will
denn sie stehen für rassismus
unterstützung von den demokraten im
kongress sie wollen im capitol 11
statuen abbauen
die persönlichkeiten der konföderierten
südstaaten darstellen damit würde dem
hass gehuldigt
die individuellen sie mit diesen staaten
geehrt werden
haben menschen versklavt dass es nichts
was wir in amerika ihren sollten die
diskussion um erinnerungskultur reicht
weiter so soll vom winde verweht vorerst
aus dem programm genommen werden weil
der film sklavenhaltung romantisiert
mascara autorennen verbieten die
konföderierten flagge und das militär
erwägt eine umbenennung von stützpunkten
die nach südstaaten generieren benannt
sind präsident trump will darüber noch
nicht mal nachdenken diese monumentalen
und sehr mächtigen basen sind zu einem
teil des großen amerikanischen erbes
geworden einer geschichte des gewinnens
sieges und der freiheit in richmond
virginia will der demokratische
gouverneur eine statue abbauen lassen
doch ein gericht untersagt dass der
kultur kampf in amerika ist voll
entbrannt
nach den usa ist brasilien weltweit am
schlimmsten betroffen von der korona
pandemie
dort wütet das virus noch immer
ungebremst allein gäste wurden knapp
33.000 neuinfektionen gemeldet
insgesamt gibt es mehr als 700 72.000
bestätigte fälle und fast 40.000 corona
tote und die dunkelziffer ist hoch denn
in den armen vierteln wird kaum getestet
christoph röck rat die bilder gleichen
sich doch die schicksale dahinter sind
immer wieder andere die korona zahlen in
brasilien steigen weiter bilden aber die
realität war weiter nicht ab viele
mutmaßliche opfer gerade in den armen
vierteln sterben zu hause ohne test ohne
in der statistik aufzutauchen
wir können wegen unserer test kapazität
heute nur die fälle testen die ins
krankenhaus eingeliefert werden
wir rechnen also dass wir nur circa zehn
bis 15 prozent der fälle wirklich
erkennen allein der sprunghaft
gestiegene bedarf an gräbern deutet das
ausmaß an
doch schon die offiziellen zahlen sind
ein politisches problem für präsident
ball szenario der weiter gegen
isolationsmaßnahmen ist so erklären
kritiker den versuch der regierung vom
wochenende die zahlen erst verzögert
dann gar nicht und dann nur noch für die
letzten 24 stunden zu melden
eine manipulation die der oberste
gerichtshof schließlich unterbindet sie
wollen die zahlen fälschen manipulieren
damit es so scheint als sei es gar nicht
so schlimm wie es tatsächlich ist
doch es regt sich widerstand
immer mehr menschen gehen gegen die
regierung auf die straße
beflügelt auch von den black lifes
matter demonstrationen in den usa am
morgen haben sie hier in der copacabana
symbolische gräber aufgeschüttet um an
das sterben zu erinnern
doch es scheint dass corona auch als
brandbeschleuniger wirkt für konflikte
die schon lange spielen in brasilien
allen voran rassismus und soziale
ungerechtigkeit
jetzt brodelt wie lange nicht mehr in
brasilien seit einigen monaten machen
sich wieder mehr flüchtlinge von
tunesien aus auf den weg nach europa vor
der tunesischen küste ist nun ein boot
mit 53 menschen gekannt hat mindestens
45 von ihnen sind dabei ertrunken
darunter zwei kinder
die küstenwache hat kaum noch hoffnung
überlebende zu finden
die migranten waren am vergangenen
wochenende aufgebrochen und wollten
offenbar nach italien zurück nach
deutschland für die einen ist heute ein
normaler arbeitstag für die anderen ein
feiertag fronleichnam die katholiken
erinnern an die gegenwart jesu christi
normalerweise sieht das so aus
prozessionen mit vielen teilnehmern in
diesem jahr aber war alles anders die
meisten prozessionen abgesagt
gottesdienste nur mit chor ohne regeln
hütter sonne wald
nicht nur für kardinal marx ist dieser
festgottesdienst im münchner
liebfrauendom zu fronleichnam ein ganz
anderer als sonst unter strengen
hygienevorschriften durften nur 70
gläubige an den feierlichkeiten die im
netz übertragen wurden teilnehmen und es
gab keine prunkvolle prozession
wir wollen in die gesellschaft hinein an
zeichen setzen und deswegen ist es mir
heute auch wichtig denen zu danken und
denen noch einmal ein wort der
wertschätzung sozusagen die in der
pandemie die ja nicht zu ende ist ihr
dies getan
dazu gehören pfleger seelsorger menschen
die obdachlosen helfen oder ihren
nachbarn und solche die sterbende
begleiten
sie wurden heute hier eingeladen und
gewürdigt die leute sind noch dankbarer
dass wir überhaupt noch kommen und
wirklich dass noch mehr wertschätzen
dass wir wirklich jeden abend steht
dieser bus da und darauf können sie sich
einfach verlassen operationen oder nicht
sind wir hier zusammen als familie und
das gibt uns stärke besonders in dieser
zeit die korona pandemie als neue chance
für den glauben und unsere gesellschaft
so sieht es der münchner erzbischof an
diesem fronleichnam einem der
wichtigsten katholischen feiertage und
unter dir norbert nach einem spannenden
spiel spessart gestern steht er jetzt
das dfb pokalfinale fest bayer gegen
bayern ja genau wobei das war ja alles
andere als eine souveräne leistung was
die münchner da gestern abend im
halbfinale gegen frankfurt gezeigt
hatten ein 2 2 1-zittersieg gegen eine
in der zweiten halbzeit starke eintracht
ein wenig hilfe benötigten die bayern
dann doch für den finaleinzug der
videobeweis musste den sieg treffer von
robert lewandowski erst bestätigen
die haben muss meiner mannschaft ein
riesenlob auch aussprechen weil sie
jetzt in diesem jahr 2020 einfach
hervorragend performt nach furiosem
start der bayern mit dem frühen 1 0
durch ivan perisic schafft der frankfurt
nach der pause gegen müde wirkende
münchner den verdienten ausgleich durch
tolle leistung speziell in der zweiten
halbzeit was wir heute gezeigt haben
hätten fast für eine überraschung
gesorgt
frankfurt bringt bayern aber nur
kurzzeitig ins wanken mehr nicht es
spricht für die mentale stärke der
münchner nur sechs minuten nach dem
ausgleich den siegtreffer zu erzielen
mitglieder der us fußball
nationalmannschaften dürfen während der
hymne wieder knien um gegen rassismus
diskriminierung und ungleichbehandlung
zu protestieren
der amerikanische fußball-verband kippte
ein entsprechendes verbot und
entschuldigte sich insbesondere bei
seinen schwarzen spielerinnen und
spielern eingeführt worden weil die
regel vor drei jahren nach dem spiel
führen michael rapino auf diese art
protestiert hatte bei der deutschen
tischtennis meisterschaft der herren hat
nach saarbrücken gestern heute
ochsenhausen das finale erreicht der
titelverteidiger bezwang rekordmeister
düsseldorf mit star spieler timo boll
der brasilianer hugo karl rahner brachte
timo boll ins wanken und ebnete damit
den einzug seiner mannschaft ins finale
in diesen vierten spiel gelingt es dem
weltranglisten-sechsten vollständig
unter druck zu setzen beim stand von 6
zu 8 im fünften satz gelingt ihm ein
unglaublicher lauf zum matchball und
sieg nach 0 2-rückstand steht es 2 zu 2
spiel 5 entscheidet carlsson gegen gau
sie der das match gewinnt das halbfinale
entscheidet titelverteidiger
ochsenhausen steht im finale
unter seinen spielern am sonntag in
frankfurt am main
danke norbert das wetter macht morgen
einen satz in den sommer hinein
die temperatur steigt wieder und dazu
gibt es im süden viel sonne
die details gleich von essent elli das
war es für heute danke für ihre
aufmerksamkeit claus kleber erwartet sie
um 21 uhr 45 zum heute-journal und wir
freuen uns morgen wieder um 19 uhr ob
sie noch einen schönen abend für sie
[Musik]
ein sogenannter und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter eine schwülwarme luft masse
erreicht uns in den nächsten tagen und
zum wochenende müssen wir sogar mit
unwettern rechnen
diese kommt aus dem osten ja und morgen
am nachmittag und abend kann es im osten
deutschlands schon erste schauer und
gewitter geben
schauen wir in die nacht da gibt es ganz
im norden viele wolken und regen
ansonsten ist es trocken nach süden hin
gibt es kaum wolken und die temperaturen
sinken auf 14 15 grad an den küsten und
6 grad am alpenrand
ja und morgen im tagesverlauf viel
sonnenschein und trockenes wetter aber
zum nachmittag dann im osten erste
schauer und gewitter die können auch
platzregen mitbringen und das bei
temperaturen bis 30 grad generell wird
es fast überall warm und über der 25
grad marke
ja und die nächsten tage am samstag gibt
es teils heftige schauer und gewitter
vor allem nach nordosten
und da kann platzregen dabei sein hagel
und sturmböen und diese gewitter die
zehn sehr langsam und sind dann
unwetterartig damit ein schöner abend